covet case numbers are still falling
nationwide and the rules are changing
when it comes to wearing masks in public
so that's putting some workers in a very
awkward position you could say at shops
and grocery stores
that are still asking customers to mask
up meg oliver is inside a supermarket in
paramus new jersey
meg is getting dicey on both sides so
what are the rules
gail good morning as you can see the
mass mandate is still in place here in
new jersey and at this stu leonard's
grocery store
but they also have locations in
connecticut and new york where customers
starting today can start taking their
masks off
but that's only for vaccinated customers
and most businesses including this one
are relying on the honor system
at stu leonard's grocery stores a change
is coming vaccinated customers in new
york and connecticut
will be able to shop mask free for the
first time in more than a year
we really want to take baby steps every
day and just be listening to our
customers and teams
leonard is a company vice president and
granddaughter of its founder
how will you know if someone's fully
vaccinated
you don't know we really are just asking
our customers to
use their best judgment and to really
come in if they are vaccinated
and we hope that that will be the case
but olivia melendez hopes customers will
continue to cover their faces
she has immunocompromised family at home
and doesn't want to take
chances you could easily just print up a
fake card or just borrow somebody else's
be like hey i'm vaccinated i don't need
to wear it like people could easily lie
about that
i personally just don't feel comfortable
with it at all and it's just a risk to
me and
my family and my co-workers in most
states business owners will have final
say on mask wearing
those asking customers to keep covering
up are worried about confrontations
i think there's going to be problems
because people are going to say i don't
have to wear a mask because they said i
don't have to wear a mask
melenda says while she knows some people
have resisted mask rules
she hasn't encountered them in stu
leonard's and as long as new jersey's
mask mandate is in place
she hopes she doesn't have to we've been
going through this for like a year
like you guys everybody should know will
you feel comfortable eventually
taking your mask off at work i think
eventually i think not for a long time
i'm not taking any risk with the
coronavirus
leonard told us 90 percent of the staff
here at stu leonards are now vaccinated
but they're asking team members to keep
wearing masks until at least memorial
day
that's to keep them as safe as possible
and also to help customers feel
comfortable
in their stores vlad mega oliver thank
you very much meg